okay here we are on YouTube you made it
baby
and II should Donald Trump run as a
third-party candidate if he doesn't get
the Republican nomination okay good
question he actually can you have to
start getting on the ballot starting
March in states in Texas so he can't do
that and then write-in candidate there
are seven or eight states that don't
even allow for that so if he doesn't win
the nomination it's not--there's no
that's right okay and if he doesn't win
the nomination what do you think is
gonna happen I mean we're we're we're
his supporters I mean historically I
mean this is their Z they're gonna be
angry oh yeah I mean in 1824 know if you
Jackson was up that's only about 18 the
election was stolen
look it's happened historically we don't
you know it's not a good thing but no I
don't think we're gonna be rioting I
mean that's not good no I think it's
great how you guys keep saying we hope
there's no rioting right you know at our
rallies we always say in the media
neighbor reports this but we always say
you know guys I've no bio no you say no
live by the way defusing Isles it's on
tape no there's also there's a video of
a black police officer great you saw
cute she's not right who went to he said
you know I just wanted to see what was
going on I went to a trump rally the
people who are making trouble with the
outside agitators right as the southern
here trying to provoke yeah and then
that could very well be true hmm okay
yeah but the sucker punch guy come on
you got to come down on him well there
was a sucker punch I don't like violence
okay great uh are the revelations of the
Panama papers by the way I don't use
Panama papers are you in it I was very
nervous sure I told you it really I
don't know where you store your money so
I don't know if you're in them uh no
likely no no Americans so far likely to
hear any changes in American policy boy
Bernie nailed that one
did you see the tape of him five years
ago saying I mean I don't know if feds
are gonna change their people you know
Panama there's like twelve other
countries that do that I mean rich
people are always gonna find it really
revelations is I really revelation that
billionaires are hiding money in tiny
countries is this a new nicely step down
alright yes he does yeah the Argentine
you guys being looked into those heads
of state being looked into I think it
gives our politicians a little bit more
backbone to do things like you know stop
the inversions it just happened that's a
big victory for the Obama administration
this week that you're not gonna have
just yet another company say oh I'm
suddenly not American anymore but you
know I'm a completely American company
for every reason other than tax purposes
I mean we've got dozens of companies in
this country that spend more on lobbying
than they do on taxes absolutely yes
yeah what is crazy when when giant
corporations pay no taxes yeah a hundred
billion dollars a hundred billion
dollars they think are being hidden away
just from America imagine the job
training we could do with a hundred
billion dollars and and by the way but
for those who saying that the argument
is always well we're gonna let the
corporation's bring the money back and
we'll tax it at a one-time rate and it's
always like a sweetheart rate like four
percent this was done
Bush did it and the promise was will
when that money comes back of course
they're gonna create jobs with it they
did nothing of the story how that they
bought hookers and be a great one
friggin job and E is Trump's plan to get
Mexico to pay for the wall oh yes that
came out this week he's uh is that
viable now how would you describe that
plan you could do it better than I could
hey so the idea would be
laughing thank you it's not an Outlook
so the way that you can do it is with
the trade-in value or ear Republicans
are happy we're optimistic people
absolutely that is true we believe the
best okay so chumps getting chumps gonna
have Mexico pay for this wall gathering
- thank you I just don't want to be sent
off to Guantanamo Bay out of you I mean
price uh Trump will [ __ ] disappear me
I mean this guy wouldn't think twice he
sued me you know I don't know he sued me
yeah yeah yeah what do you think of that
lawsuit Andy I remember that yeah yeah
yeah I mean talked about that I mean
come on that was pretty dumb yeah it was
like whether or not he was in a rank
exact yeah I mean ice and you said you I
said I as a joke I offered him five
million dollars if he could prove his
father was an orangutan right and he
went into any when it's a court with his
birth certificate right as if it was
gonna say orangutan and said I want my
money you got to admit he's a little
fins important that that first event
precedent which will set by your friend
Larry Flynt that Supreme Court case it
is important on delivery that's true he
was Jerry Falwell making the joke about
his baby's mother and outhouse right all
right so you have to be able to make
these jokes he's got a right company
shouldn't be so litigious we like
Scientologists like I'm willing I read
oh they're so anyway what about the what
about the plan that the plan - no he's
gonna he's gonna stop the remittances
back to Mexico you tax the remittances
or I mean they're all sorts of things
when money moves in one country to
another that you could do you could do a
foreign trade deal with Mexico where
there's a percentage of goods coming in
until the walls paid for but don't you
think that if we if we screw with their
economy it'll make more people come over
because their economy is bad I mean I I
know I know
works why are we pretending why are we
still pretending that Donald Trump wants
to be President
all right this is is a publicity stunt
that winter I oh I'm telling you 3:00 in
the morning when the ambient noise is
off he's gonna go to Andy's very real
bees just say Andy's do be like George
Costanza you gotta get me out of this
I
I'm doing everything to get out of it
I've offended everybody pause this is
too painful for him not really serious
about and by the way I was the one guy
who always said he was serious about
yeah he's very suburban for him but I
always said this is not a publicity hunt
on this guy has an ego as big as all
outdoors and yeah like he would hate it
when he walked in the room and they play
held with the chief oh love it exactly
I'm just we're very very very lucky to
be boarded by two countries that
actually like us and are our friends
that's right for you keval early about
about alienating Mexico and Canada we're
very fortunate
Rosa barbers like us and we like that
let's have [ __ ] that up Andy all right
remember 1824 yes 1824 the only time an
election was stolen
oh eight did you play the organ time
1960 right well my other time Kennedy
Joe Kennedy put up some votes
oh also it didn't what about the 1870s
about 2000 let's retry push me more I'll
do it right now I'm ready gentlemen boy
all right I could name over
picking them every president in order
and not because I memorize it because I
know the history hole last question will
the Pope meeting with Bernie yeah Bernie
sands gonna meet with the Pope I noticed
none of the other candidates got an
invitation from Frank okay
will the Pope with a Pope meeting with
Bernie Sanders influence the outcome of
our election in any way no it's kind of
cool I mean you know I think it's kind
of cool that the Pope recognized the
fellow socialist fact that you know yeah
anything alike they think I like all
right thank you everybody thank you
we're gonna go